I want to give the highest appraisal to the actions of
Russian soldiers and officers they
act courageously professionally
heroically I say clay how did you get
where
it was to the north of the code and arrived born
from a chicken all the stops got to throw
some stew although the illusion everyone does not
believe our parts of berlin do not want churches
equipped  pray yes it turns out than
dirt
[music]
get out the
critical company do not go sloppy
waiting for you here
we
have no desire don to fight against
ukraine and against the ukrainian people we
all love you today we want war
came to
[ __ ] the [ __ ] yet to the other world went to
given this is such a love to give or the
Chechen people as dan operations the people
and other Russian puppets therefore
Shannon and Ukrainians do not consider these people
Chechens these are not Chechens this is a shame of the
Chechen people President Putin and the Russian
Ministry of Defense clearly
stated and  clearly stated  that
I won’t strike at civilian targets
[music]
guys this garbage flew into
melitopol private sector
shells
that let’s bottle it is overestimated
now the Chernobyl nuclear power plant is controlled by
Russian airborne troops
together with the Ukrainian
security unit they provide security
no battles are being fought here
[music]
all the guards from the national guard of
ukraine surrendered without a fight, by the way,
these shots show how the
ukrainian national guardsmen arrived here to change duty
guards carry the
revival of the nuclear arsenal of ukraine
one of the key dreams of the stubborn
Bandera people who are eager to cause at least
some damage to the damn moskal
but since the dreams of Svidomo in this
matter are far ahead of real
possibilities, it cannot be ruled out that the goose
uses available means, for example, a
dirty bomb stuffed with radioactive
waste from Chernobyl,
it is a
water blockade interrupted, Crimea will soon be
ready to receive water from the north  Crimean
canal today our military engineers
blew up a concrete dam that
Ukrainian nationalists built in
2014 to cut off the water supply to the inhabitants of the
peninsula  and what’s with the Crimea, I’m
Styopka’s romance, I’m a former member of the corps and
all our brothers handed over
their weapons for a long time because I don’t understand that there is no
chance they were developed in two hours in just
2 hours 8 rows lurked out of 2 hours
[ __ ] up well, how so
[music]
Russia will ensure the demilitarization of Ukraine,
ask to provide 12 to that Ukraine, we
suffered too much from Nazism and the Ukrainian
people suffered too much from Nazism and
so that you could turn a blind
eye to all this, with all your attempts, your
propaganda that floods your brains and
hearts, do not imagine me until 40 years old
who lived in Russian-speaking Kharkov with a
surname and Venediktova radical Kai and
nationalists we are all
nationalists this is Ukraine  Ntsy from Kerch
Donetsk to Lviv already the city of Ternopil
nationalists are those who love their
homeland and we are on our land to our country
and you do not have a title beyond the 16th corner of the world to
Ukraine, but Akira Toyya volunteers
shoulder shoulders with the Ukrainian people to fight
against the aggressor they are not  zagalna keel
brush has already exceeded a thousand people and
applications continue to go over and
[music]
ukraine is fighting for its freedom
this is a great patriotic war for
Ukrainians real Chechens with you shoulders
screaming with you are fighting today shedding
blood shed and for the last eight years I
[music]
two  Portuguese students who blamed the
Ukrainian border guards in Russia, the media
managed to get into Poland, while
other foreigners and especially
citizens of African and Asian countries
continue to complain about
discrimination against them
[applause]
[music]
although Clara stole a
kulbi himself on lapis diana sports
italmac from that you judge t  [ __ ] him right away time [music] [music] in order to protect people who for eight years have been subjected to genocide bullying by Kyiv in the regime I will put I we all start against him and we are asked from the artillery to write down your fight [music] now in the center [music]